[Music]
Godzilla king of the monsters has just
received its second trailer release and
there's a lot to unpack from the teaser
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the monsters involved in it as
well as some of the Easter eggs that we
see this video may contain spoilers but
it is a bit too early to say yet and
everything right now is just a theory
but you have been warned
without the weigh and definition and
welcome to the channel where I roon it
so you don't have to okay so the trailer
opens with Madison sending a distress
call only to be greeted by a voice that
is completely drowned out and deafened
by the unmistakable sound of a monster
we learn from the trailer that Madison
and her mother dr. Emma Russel have been
kidnapped by an organization that
believed that the Titans are the first
and rightful rulers of the planet from
the surroundings one could guess that
they are currently at the Arctic
installation where King Ghidorah awakens
and throughout the trailer we can piece
together that godzilla arrives to stop
him Ghidorah is initially pictured
behind a large wall of ice and gets
woken up before being unleashed on the
world Ghidorah has the capacity to fire
gravity beams from its mouth and can
discharge electromagnetic fields and
travel through space in the trailer we
see the giant beast making easy work of
Boston and even demolishing a Dunkin
Donuts sign and was arguably one of the
best or worst product placement shots
ever
Godzilla fights it at both the base and
city and the scenes are very reminiscent
of Batman V Superman aesthetically I
just hope the fight doesn't end because
their mother is called the Mothra to get
it like Martha no never mind anyway that
brings me on to my next point
Martha a two can be seen in the trailer
throughout Mothra rises in China but
actually seems to be on the same side as
Godzilla it makes sense to have more
good monsters as just g-man on his own
would really not stand a chance the blue
light that emanates from both Mothra and
Godzilla might highlight that they're on
the same side and even friends that go
alike Dunkin Donuts together no wonder
they're so angry we also get flashes of
Rodin who rises from a volcano spewing
ash
and lava from the trailer it appears
that Rodin travels to Washington DC
completely destroying it in the process
with a massive wind gusts that even
makes people fly into the air we see the
US military and G team which one can
assume stands for Godzilla
flying in to meet the monster and this
scene is obviously saying up a big
showdown the monarch Sciences viral
marketing website has teased two dozen
Titans on earth and it appears that
there's a fifth monster in the film when
we see giant crab legs erupting from the
ground
however this monster is a name so it's
difficult to do more than speculate at
this moment there is an exchange that
highlights that there are two sides of
the story with one disputing that the
monsters are here to protect us whilst
the other states that they are here to
destroy us in the dialogue exchange
humanity is called Godzilla's pet which
highlights that he is indeed our
protector so we can guess that
everything else is against us other than
best mate Mothra whilst we may be as pet
Godzilla still gets held captive and
there's a great shot of this in the
trailer overall it makes for a stunning
set piece and perhaps showcases that
medicine is the reason that the beast
rises up to defend us either way I can't
wait to see how the battles play out on
the big screen and this has certainly
got me amped up for the main event so
what are your thoughts on the second
Godzilla king of the monsters trailer
are you excited for the film and which
monsters do you want to see most comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of the leaked Spider
Man far from home trailer which would be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who were mad into monsters so if
that's the kind of thing you like it
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]